-And finally, it is Wednesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you five
different tweets and we're all
going to vote on whether you
like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Yep.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want.
And we're gonna see the results
live.
Higgins, Roots, you guys have
clickers too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out live
on the show so that you can all
like it and "wetweet" it.
-Whoo!
-It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys ready?
Everyone have your clickers?
Hands up. Hands up if you got
the clickers.
Alright, perfect. Alright, good.
Alright, first tweet. It says...
[ Light laughter ]
Mm.
-Wow, silence.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe they're laughing
on the inside.
-On the inside of their thigh?
-Yeah.
Don't talk about the inside of
anyone's thigh.
-What's that?
It's Valentine's Day.
-I don't even know if I have to
check the votes on this one,
but let's just do it for fun.
Let's see the results.
-Ooh!
[ Sad tuba ]
-Wow.
-64.
-No one got stabbed by a pencil
in grade school?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Four people did, yeah.
So it work --
the math works out.
It's correct. Everyone's --
Everyone's clickers work.
Alright. This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
Well, now I feel like the Roots
are playing the music
lighter and lighter.
Yeah, I mean, that sells
the bit, you know?
Alright, that's not gonna work
either.
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
It's probably worse than
the first one.
Oh! Hey, alright, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Not bad.
-It hit triple digits.
-Yeah. They don't necessarily
get better.
-No.
-I will say that.
[ Laughter ]
This next one here says...
It is getting that way.
-Yeah.
-It is getting that way where
I'm like...
It is getting that way. Alright.
You all voted?
Let's see the results.
Alright. Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Next up, it says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-That's pretty good actually.
I like that idea.
That's not bad.
Cast your votes here.
Alright. Let's see the results
on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
Yeah!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's gonna be the hit.
That's gonna be the winner.
-That took the lead.
-I'll do the last one just
for fun, but that one's gonna be
the winner.
This last one is...
[ Laughter ]
Cast your votes.
Alright, let's see the results.
-I don't know.
That one might win.
-You like that one?
-I like that one.
-No, I think it's the one
before that.
Everyone's laughing at that one.
I don't know.
Alright, here we go.
Let's see the results.
-Oh!
-Oh, that's right.
The winner is number four.
[ Dinging ]
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet" and enjoy.